The argument on the other side
is when people are distributing,
and I'm going to use the big air quotes,
hate speech,
that's when it gets slippery to me
because who's to decide what's hate speech
and what's not? Hate speech. I mean,
I've seen people make some ridiculous
fucking statements about all sorts of
people that are inaccurate and they do
that in order to categorize them and
pigeonhole them in, in an easily
definable and dismissible co, uh,
characterization. You know, you just
decide, hey, that Bill Ottman guy,
that guy's a this. Oh, he's a
radical that and he believes in this,
so fuck him. And they're like,
okay, fuck him, sweep more. I,
and then cancel culture comes in like,
we're going to cancel Bill Ottman.
We're not listening to him anymore.
You know,
he lied to us about his source
or whatever the fuck you doing.
Have you heard of Daryl Davis? No, I have
not. Once I forgot Dow. David's your boy.
He's my boy. He, he, you'll, you'll, I
haven't met him, but he's, he's my way.
I want him to be my boy.
So he is a black man who befriended
hundreds of members of the KKK and he got
them all to leave.
He got them to leave the to 200 members.
Wow. After he was like, yeah,
I'm just going to talk to you.
Really he would you ever see the n a w
Kamau Bell's a show when he visited with
those white supremacists? Not
that specific one. Yeah, it was.
It's really good because
he's such a nice guy.
He's so like easy to get along with that.
They were like sort of,
they let the guard down
around them and you know,
you get to see these people
kind of confused that they
liked this guy. You know?
That's why I think initiating human
contact via the social networks,
like that's really important.
But to play devil's advocate,
it's one of the worst ways for people
to express themselves in a way where you
consider other human beings experiences
and feelings and the way they're going
to receive what you're saying
because there's no social cues.
You're not interacting with them,
you're not looking at them in the eyes.
It's one of the weirder forms
of communication between
human beings and one that
I would argue we have
not really necessarily a
successfully navigated it yet.
I agree.
I was actually saying that I think we
should use social media more to get people
to get together in real life. Do
you know who uh, Megan Phelps is?
No. She, uh, was uh, with
the Westboro Baptist Church.
Uh, you know, the, the, the
famous one that the protests,
those soldier's funerals and you know,
and,
and anything gay and they're
like ruthlessly viciously
fundamental Christians
where,
you know,
they do a lot of protesting at funerals
and to a lot of stuff to try to get,
she was with them for,
for the longest time and then got on
Twitter and through communicating on
Twitter when you meet her,
you would never believe it in a
million years that she was ever this
fundamentalist and that she was ever
some mean person sending hateful messages
to people because their son
was gay or whatever it was.
Now she's completely cured of it. She's
has no contact with the church anymore.
She's married, has a kid,
she's completely outside of it.
She does podcasts now and give Ted talks
and speaks about radicalization and
about how she was kind of indoctrinated
in, grew up in this family and her,
her grandfather, Fred Phelps
was this, you know, he's like,
it's a fucking mean guy. Like a really
mean v. He's the God hates fags guy.
You know, they would have those
signs that they would hold up.
But at the soldier's funerals, I mean,
he's like really inflammatory stuff.
But through Twitter,
through her communicating with people
on Twitter and specifically her now
husband,
like he,
he cured her like it just with rational
discourse and communication and she was
old will change. They will change. And
so that's why banning them. I mean,
I saw on a recent podcast you've
been talking about redemption.
Yeah. So, but I'm curious,
what do you think people,
what is, how does that look
like? Well, timber, it, look,
in the case of like Megan Phelps,
that's a real thing, right?
She really did change. Um, another
example is Christian peak Illini.
Do you know who he is?
He was a white supremacists KKK member
guy who's been on Sam Harris's podcast.
He's also done some Ted talks who now
speaks out against it and talks about how
he's indoctrinated and
talks about how lost he was.
Now he was brought into this
ideology. Um, there are,
there's many people like that
all over the world. Um, uh,
Majid Majid was another perfect
example. He was an Islamist, I mean,
he was,
you know,
trying to form a caliphate was
literally thinking about radical Islamic
terrorism as being some sort of a
solution. Now he's the opposite.
Now he's trying to get people to leave
and he's trying to get people to be more
reasonable and secular or
see what happened to him.
He ain't got punched in
the street. Yeah. Um, yeah.
Some guy called him a
fucking packy I guess,
and punched him in the head and fucked
his head up and he's got this giant
cotton in his head from a ring
and his face is swollen up.
But apparently they have the
guy on video and um, you know,
they think they're going to
be able to arrest the guy.
I've had magic on the show.
He's a super nice guy. The,
the hard thing is that all right.
Yes,
we see these transformations take place.
It makes us feel warm inside and yes,
people, people can change, but at
the same time, what are people have,
should people have to go
apologize to Twitter? Oh, I'm
sorry. Like can I come back?
Right. I mean that's not like sometimes
people are going to think completely
differently than you and you just have
to deal with it. And that should be okay.
We shouldn't force people to come in
to our way of thinking in order to have
discourse. No, that's a good point.
That's a very good point. Um,
and like who is to decide what this
path to redemption is and whether or not
you've completed it,
right?
Who was decided like maybe you are a,
a hyper radical lefty and maybe Jamie's
points of view and yours are just never
going to line up. So you're like,
fuck him. He's banned for life,
which a lot of people
have been banned for life.
And when you look at some of the
infractions, they'd been banned for it.
They're like, boy, I don't know about
that one. That doesn't really make sense.
Almost none of the high pro profile
banning cases make much sense.
It's like a short term solution
that's creating a longterm problem.
Yeah,
that's really what it is.
So I just think that we
have to talk about it more.
I don't know. I, it's like why can't we
just get everyone to talk about it? Yeah.
I get the same time. I mean it's
like we're just wasting time here.
Well,
sort of,
but I also think we're figuring it out
as we go along with a bunch of different
competing ideologies. Um, you know,
you have yours, which like you dude,
you look like a hacker.
Unlike House of cards,
you'll look like a guy you call in
to break into the, the, the
mainframe server. Not that honestly,
I believe you're not,
I hang out on to get lab in checkout code,
but I did. I cannot code.
I cannot coach bad claim.
I'm not claiming to be a
developer. No, these people are,
I know there's another level.
It is incredible. I understand,
right? Yeah. I get it. Well that's
like if someone says to me like,
you're an MMA fighter, I'm
like, I'm definitely not.
They are another fucking level.
Like there's a different like, yeah,
I know a little martial arts, but
just, just settle the fuck down. Right.
Same kind of thing.
I think though that you,
your ideology is going to be your,
your point of view and perspective is
going to be very different than maybe
someone who's like a radical Marxist,
you know,
it shouldn't they be allowed to post
on the site to someone who's like an
extreme socialist. Someone
like a AOC. You know, someone,
someone who thinks that we should give
money to people who are unwilling to work,
someone who thinks that we should try
to engineer society and tax the top x
percent, you know, 70 something
percent of their income.
There's a lot of those different people
and we have to figure out how to,
to make it so that,
well,
we have to figure out a way to make
it so all the ideas can compete in the
marketplace of ideas.
Right.
All these different ideas can compete
and we can find out which one is better
and we could find out which one is better.
Yeah.
You don't always find out which
one is better though. Right.
You find out which one is most people. I
mean, that's what happened with Hitler,
right? Well, you don't really find
out what's better. You find out what,
what's got more juice behind it.